[Música]
más economía hoy en directo a América
con Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
bienvenido de nuevo acá estamos y ya con
la apertura de Wall Street además Bueno
pues interesantes seguramente los datos
de Wall Street después de la noticia
económica del día y es la compra del
First repablic Bank por parte de otro
gran banco de Estados Unidos de Qué
banco se trata Rodrigo una compra
realizada nada más y nada menos que por
el banco más grande de Estados Unidos
con más de 220 años de antigüedad que
busca dar seguridad al delicado sector
bancario con esto JP Morgan Chase tomará
entonces la mayoría de activos y tomará
todos los depósitos del bank luego de
que este no haya logrado presentar un
plan de rescate ante las autoridades
financieras de Estados Unidos y luego de
que la semana pasada informara que había
perdido más de 100 mil millones de
dólares en depósitos en el primer
trimestre de este año y que en su
momento causó un desplome de sus
acciones en un casi 50% llegó el 49,8
más o menos recordemos que todo este
escenario ocurre dos meses después
después de que el banco sufriera de una
salida masiva de depósitos lo que hizo a
las autoridades desplegar este plan de
emergencia este lunes la cooperación
Federal de seguros de depósitos embargo
al prestamista y estima Pues que esta
entidad informó de ventas al GP Morgan y
me imagino Juan Pablo que no habrá sido
una compra barata la del cess Republic
Band de cuánto se trata de qué cifra
estamos hablando vamos entonces a las
cifras Y eso es lo que miraremos a
continuación porque con esta noticia se
conoció que en préstamos se tomarán 173
mil millones de dólares esto el JP
Morgan tomará también en valores 3 mil
millones de dólares y en depósitos unos
92 mil millones de dólares de dólares
datos que se conocieron recientemente
también que esta entidad también
confirmó recientemente y todo esto
tomado por el fallido banco pero
entonces JP Morgan compartirá con la
cooperación Federal de seguros los de
depósitos tanto las pérdidas como las
posibles recuperaciones que se den en
los próximos 18 meses y en adelante ya
que al final es una cooperación entre el
banco y está con federación vamos a
hablar ahora de lo que han dicho tanto
el banco como las autoridades
estadounidenses sobre esta compra tan
importante y empecemos por el JP Morgan
porque dijo lo siguiente abro comillas
nuestro gobierno nos invitó a nosotros y
a otros a dar paso al frente y así lo
hicimos nuestra fortaleza financiera
nuestras capacidades y nuestro modelo de
negocio nos permitieron desarrollar una
oferta para ejecutar la operación de
forma que se minimizarán los costes para
el fondo de seguros de depósitos otros
de los que se pronunció también para dar
tranquilidad a los mercados y al sector
bancario fue el departamento del tesoro
quien dijo lo siguiente el tesoro se
siente alentado por el hecho de que esta
institución se resolviera con el menor
coste para el fondo de seguro de
depósitos Y de forma que se protegieran
todos los depositantes ambos concuerdan
en sus declaraciones y que se sabe Ahora
tanto de los depósitos pero sobre todo
de los depositantes porque seguramente
los que ya estaban en el ferre public
ahora formarán parte automáticamente de
JP Morgan exactamente como lo dice Usted
los depositantes entonces
pasarán directamente a ser depositantes
de JP Morgan y las 84 oficinas del bank
reabrirán como sucursales de JP Morgan
en los ocho estados que tienen presencia
así lo confirmó la cooperación Federal
de seguros de depósitos este lunes en el
siguiente comunicado que dijo abro
comillas como parte de la transacción
las 84 oficinas del esfuerzo public Bank
en 8 estados reabrirán como sucursales
de JP Morgan Chase Bank hoy durante el
horario comercial normal todos los
depositantes de fuerza pública se
convertirán en depositantes de JP Morgan
eh Chase Bank y tendrán acceso completo
a todos sus depósitos también aclaró lo
siguiente y dijo los clientes del falso
public deben continuar usando su
sucursal existente hasta que reciban
avisos del GP Morgan de que se ha
completado los cambios del sistema para
que permitir también las otras
sucursales de JP Morgan que también
puedan procesar sus cuentas Así que
deben esperar pues hasta entonces pues
mucha más seguridad para todos los
clientes yo no quisiera estar en esa
situación desde luego Así es no la harás
compleja bastante compleja es compleja
pero buenas noticias en todo caso vamos
ahora con Los indicadores de las bolsas
porque nos comentabas que ya ha abierto
Wall Street Así es que otros indicadores
podríamos revisar hoy si no son los de
los dos bancos de la importante noticia
de hoy las acciones del Force public
Bank se detuvieron tras conocerse las
noticias mientras las acciones del GP
Morgan rondaban los 4% de ganancias y
seguros se dispararán mucho más Durante
este día en Wall Street pues Juan Pablo
Muchas gracias por este repaso económico
Seguiremos atentos también mañana más
probablemente Sigamos hablando del mismo
tema probablemente mañana con mucho más
de economía